All right, everyone.
Welcome to the TDPs seminar
today. And before we introduce
our invited speaker, let's go
over some rules and logistics.
First of all, please mute
yourself during the talk and
please use the chat room to post
your questions so that we can
address them in q&a session at
the end. Second, today's DDPS
seminar is open to external
audiences there will no classify
discussion is allowed so watch
out. Finally, the talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in
our YouTube channel. Okay,
that's about it. Let me
introduce our speaker today. It
is an honor to host H. S.
Udaykumar , who is a roll Carver
professor of mechanical
engineering, and Associate Dean
for Research graduate programs
and faculty in the College of
Engineering at the University of
Iowa. He received a BTech in
aerospace engineering from the
Indian Institute of Technology
and MS and PhD degrees from the
University of Florida. He has
published over 150 journal
papers in varied topic areas of
biomedical and mechanical
engineering. His research focus
is on multiscale modeling and
simulation of a wide range of
moving boundary problems in
thermo mechanical systems
ranging from phase change
thermal stories, biomedical
applications involving
cardiovascular and gastro in
intestine, intestinal mechanics,
energetic material dynamics and
proportions and munitions, and
multi phase flows at all speeds.
He has been supported by grants
from NSF, we take her
foundation, biomedical
engineering, Grant and I add H
and we research grants and the
multiple concurrent grants from
various DoD agencies. Today,
they will present an exciting
topic which is data driven
multiscale simulations for
materials by design of
anesthetic materials. Please
enjoy and expect a wonderful
talk now without further ado,
let me pass the baton today by
asking one random question as
usual, since it is Friday, in
order to recommend a movie for
the weekend. Whoever wants to
watch movie this weekend?
Today's random question is What
is your favorite movie? Will
they expect that?
No, I didn't expect that. My
favorite movie. My favorite
movie would be
Apollo Apollo 13. I think that's
my favorite movie. Because it's,
you know, I loved how Tom Hanks
I love space. And I always show
that movie to my students as a
great motivating movie for
engineers, you know, because
that particular scene when they
cobbled together the device to
scrub the co2 in the module, you
know, is an excellent example of
hands on engineering in a very,
very high pressure situation.
And of course, I forced my
daughters to watch it as a
Christmas movie, which doesn't
go very well in our house. But
yeah, that's my favorite movie.
Thank you. Thank you for sharing
it. Okay, the stage is yours.
Okay.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Yeah, thanks for for inviting
me. You know, being to Livermore
I was saying earlier this year,
and it's great to be returning
back, although virtually. I hope
you can see my screen still
young soon.
Okay, great. Great. Um,
so yeah, so I will, I'll be
talking today about data driven
multiscale simulations for
energetic materials. This is
work that is funded by the Air
Force Mudie program. And by
there are parts of it that are
NSF dmrf Program grant funded
and also parts of it from a CRO.
And I do want to mention that
this is collaborative work with
Steven Beck, who is actually the
deep learning person. I'm a
collaborator on this. And fun,
who's also a deep learning
person working with Steve back
at Virginia. And we've been
working on this for for quite a
while now, I would say last
three or four years in the
Marine Program. So I'm going to
try to give a you know, I was
kind of deciding whether to go
do eat or go broad, and I'd
settle for somewhere in the
middle. So it might be, you
know, not wholly satisfying for
everybody, depending on what
they prefer. But hopefully it
will give you a sense for what
what we have done so far and
where we are heading with this.
Okay.
Okay, so. So
I don't know whether everybody
is familiar with energetic
materials, I will assume there
are others who are not in
energetic, so I'll give a very
brief account of what we're
doing here. So, experiments,
various types of experiments
show that energetic materials
are very sensitive, obviously,
and their sensitivity depends on
the microstructure of the
material. So, you know, here is
an example of a sensitivity
curve. This particular one is
called James curve, on the x
axis is what's called the power
flux and the y axis is what's
called energy fluence, you can
think of the x axis as being the
pressure shock pressure, and the
y axis is being the shock pulse
width, or a flyer thickness. So
typically, these are impact
experiments with a flyer coming
in at a certain velocity. So x
axis is the shock pressure
induced by the flyer and the y
axis is the thickness of the
pulse. And in this plane, the
curve separates above the curve
is critical in the sense that
the explosive, or the energetic
material will will detonate and
below the curve, it will not
detonate. So it's the
criticality curve. And you can
see that for two different micro
structures, class three and
class five of each MX This is
prestige MX, you can see that
the criticality envelopes are
very different that is, you
know, it, the material
sensitivity is significantly
influenced by the
microstructure. In particular,
it's influenced by the porosity
of the material, you can see
that in those micro structures,
there are all these great cracks
and pores and so on. And so the
the prevalence of these sites
determine determines the
criticality curve for these
metals. So, and this is not just
one experiment, there are, you
know, scores of experiments that
show various dependencies on the
microstructure. So this is the
fundamental kind of underlying
feature of what we're going to
try to understand. Through our
work. What we want want to do is
predictive models for indirect
materials. And they are
inherently multi scale because
as I said, the eventual fate of
the explosiveness, sensitivity
and so on all the material at
the macro scale depends on
what's going on in the
microstructure, which I shall
call the mezzo scale for the
purpose of this talk. And then,
of course, what happens here is
determined by the molecular
scale properties of the
material, you know, what is its
strength? In particular, you
know, how does it what is its
equation of state and other
thermo physical properties. So,
there is a telescoping of
molecular scale properties on to
measure scale properties, and
then all the way to macro scale.
So, we need to build all of this
connectivity across scales in
order to predictively simulate
what's going to happen to an
energetic material, when it's
chock loaded in my talk is going
to be all about shock loading,
because that's the regime of
interest. At least in my work,
there are lots of sub shock,
detonations and so on, but we
won't be covering that that type
of event in this talk. So,
fundamentally, the mechanism
that leads to sensitivity at the
measure scale is when you when
you lower the shock, you find
hotspots and these hotspots
typically localized and defects
in the material. So this could
be cracks or pores or something.
There are many, many mechanisms
of hotspots formation from these
defects. But in the shock
regime, or high shock regime,
when we're talking about you
know, 10 GPA plus or even, let's
say six GPA plus shock loading,
the primary cause of
localization is the collapse of
pores. So these pores collapse.
Strength does matter, but
they're it's nearly a
hydrodynamic collapse. And when
they collapse, there is jetting
and other form other high speed
phenomena that happen just like
cavitation bubbles. And you form
a hotspot and hotspots then
trigger reactions, and then the
reaction front propagates and
then fills the material. And
that then the, you know, it's
off to the races at that point.
And if there is a coupling
between this reaction and the
shock, the shock will then
transition to a detonation and
then you get what is called
shock to detonation transition,
and you get, you know, full,
full blow up for the metal. So
that's the mechanism that we
want to capture. Now this has
been forever A very long time,
you know, especially exemplified
by the by the phenomenal work of
Craig Tarver and others, you had
Livermore and other labs as
well. Typically, these these
phenomena of the hotspot
formation and mesoscale
phenomena leading to the
macroscale detonation were
typically inserted into hydro
codes by using what are called
Burn models or reactive burn
models. There are many, many
flavors of these, you know,
depending on on what your speed
is, you can, you can use many of
these which are well calibrated
for some particular formulations
of energetic materials. But a
common one or a popular one is
credit, Tarver and others, Turbo
Nichols, a lot of people live a
more contributing to this. It's
called the ignition and growth
model where there's an ignition
rate term, that is pressure that
is dependent on the density and
the compressibility, the
material and the great term
growth rate term of hotspots
that is tragic dependent. So
this is a semi empirical model
phenomenological model, where
all these parameters, ie x and
so on are fit to experiments.
And so there are lots of
experiments conducted for each
population. And then you get
these models. Now, these are the
traditional routes of empirical
empirical burn models. What we
mean by data driven models is
that we are going to use
simulations, as opposed to
physical experiments to obtain
these ignition and growth rate
parameters. Right. So so this
is, the burden then is placed on
how well you can simulate the
phenomena. And there are lots of
uncertainties there for even for
quite common materials like HX,
and TTB, and so on. And then
we're going to try to extract
data in some meaningful form
from the mesoscale simulations.
And then we're going to
construct these ignition and
growth rates from those
simulations. So this is a data
driven approach that we're going
to take. So multi scaling is
necessary. Just to kind of recap
all of that, multi scaling is
necessary measure scale
phenomena play a very large
role, particularly hotspot
phenomena. And we have to
somehow bring together these
hotspot phenomena into a burn
model. And we are choosing the
path of a data driven burn model
that is informed by direct
numerical simulations. So that's
the overall trajectory here. So,
so essentially, to kind of put
that in a broader context that
applies to a wide range of
materials, we are developing
data driven structure, Property
Performance linkages for
heterogeneous energetic metals.
And so that's, that's the
overarching theme here. So just
to give a sense for how, but in
our particular case, we are
approaching this, and this is,
you know, not very uncommon,
this would be a standard route
for anybody pursuing this
activity. So the structure part
consists of, you know, images
that we might get off an
energetic material, this is a
pressed energetic material I'm
showing here, but it could be a
PBX plastic bonded explosive,
where you would have in the
formulation, you would have some
kind of binder, and then you
would have the crystals and then
you would have porosity, so
there'll be three phases there,
here, we have two phases, what
one would do do is once given a
particular microstructure,
suppose we want to predict the
sensitivity of the material that
has this particular
microstructure, we can you know,
extract by sampling this
microstructure, otherwise just
statistical analysis, we can
obtain some idea of, you know
what to characterize its
morphology. So, we would get
some PDFs of, you know, wide
size distributions or wide other
features of the voids, you know,
surface specific surface area of
the voids, and so on and so
forth. So, that's, that's the
first structural analysis part.
The second part would be the
property determination. So, one
will do direct numerical
simulations to extract
properties of the material, for
example, its sensitivity, and
one would then take those
simulations and inform some DD
models. And in our particular
case, we have developed three
different types of DD models,
data driven here. I try not to
say data driven to too often
I'll just say BD. And the three
different types are what we call
what I call message, park and
missile. They're all of course,
appropriately and creatively
named to do you know,
exercise our creative Creativity
in this project, very limited
exercise. But those are, those
are our models, I will explain
what message is, what Park is I
will leave out missile missile
is a model that we just recently
have sent out into the world as
a publication. And that's still
not fully, fully established. So
I'm going to talk about missile,
sorry, message and Mark Park,
two different types of data
driven models, when we take
these data driven models and
feed it to macro scale
hydrocarbons as the ignition of
growth rates, and then we
predict the sensitivity. So this
structure here, the structure
part, the property part and the
performance part. So that's
those are the three things. And
we have linked all of these in
multiscale framework
successfully in in two different
efforts. So I'll summarize those
two efforts today.
Okay, so. So
just very briefly, 10,000 foot
view message is, is a data
driven model that employs
Gaussian random process
surrogate modeling techniques.
And we develop this, you know,
for the last five years or so,
and I'll show some, some
capabilities of that. But I'm
going to focus today more on
Park, which is the deep learning
approach and spend a lot of time
on this one missile is something
that's a semi analytical data
driven approach that we have
recently come up with this, it's
it's fast and dirty. It may not
be as physically sophisticated,
or accurate as Park and Miss
message, but it does a fairly
good job of predicting energetic
material sensitivity. So those
are the three types of models.
And out of all these three
models, we extract the very same
thing, which is the ignition and
growth rates in an in an IG
model framework. And then we can
put those into a macro scale
code. So the primary goal of our
DD modeling effort is to bridge
the measures what I call the
mezzo scale, which is the
microstructure and the macro
scale, which is the homogenized
behave material and, and provide
the closure models for the macro
scale. And so it's in this
structure Property Performance
Framework. We have different
packages that we have, we have
so far constructed. The
overarching package that deals
with the structure part is
called matter IQ, which is a
Python and pi torch. package.
And then we do all the
simulations the mezzo scale as
well as macroscale simulation
with an in house code called
scimitar 3d, which is a Fortran
95. So that is basically our
workhorse solver solver for lots
of problems. So just to describe
very briefly in a couple of
slides what scimitar 3d is, so
similar 3d semadar, 3d stands
for solver for computing
emerged, moving interfaces and
transport with adaptive
refinement in 3d. And these
were, you know, publications
that our group put out, you
know, as for the last decade or
so, various kinds of problems
solved with seminar training,
just to show a variety of things
that we've done. So we've done
problems of high speed impact,
you know, computation of real
geometries, micro structures and
so on damage mechanics, poor
collapse, of course, three
dimensional and two dimensional
course for collapse in HX and
other materials, fragmentation,
impact and fragmentation and
blast wave interaction with
particles. So, compressible
multi material multi phase flows
is what scimitar 3d is capable
of doing. It is a cartesian grid
fixed cartesian grid oil Arian
sharp interface solver, which
means that all the all the
interfaces you see here between
materials is treated sharply and
tracked very much similar to
front tracking, but using level
sets. So it's a level set based
techniques. So what you see
here, for example, or zero level
sets of the plate and an
impactor and so we track
explicitly the level sets. So
it's a level set based
interface. And it's called
adaptive local refinement to get
features that are very fine. And
it's paralyzed and uses image
processing to process micro
structures. So we can go
directly from an image to full
blown calculation on a fixed
mesh, using, you know, semadar,
3d, so everything, everything on
the mesh is described in the
form of level sets. Okay, so, so
that's the solver and we're
going to use that I'm going to
not talk about the solver
anymore, because that's what
we're going to use For all our
simulations. So the first
approach for the DD modeling is
message. And this was this paper
came out in 2018. And we've used
this for many, many things since
then. And in the in the message
approach, what we do is we
bridge the scales between the
measure scale, that is the
microstructure and the macro
scale, to get the performance
simulation, we bridge it using
single pore collapse
simulations. So this is
important as a distinction, the
single pore collapse simulations
are very fast, you can do
hundreds of them in a couple of
days. And then you can collect
the data from the single pole
simulations. And what we do is
we we get this hypersurface, or
a surrogate model for the
ignition and growth rates of the
single poles as a function of
the shock pressure, the shock
pulse width, the porosity, the
diameter of the voids are the
other size and shape of the
voids, these three parameters
are size and shape of the voids,
and then we get a surrogate
model. And the surrogate model
is used to close the macroscale
simulation. So that's, that's
message. And so just to show an
example of how message works,
the workflow of it, suppose we
have micro structures, and these
were provided to us by AFRL
Eglin
from Eric Wiley and Chris Bolex
group. So we have these pressed
HMS micro structures, we know
that ferocity, and we know the
size of it, we can take these
micro structures, and we can
analyze them to obtain things
like the probability density
functions of the Void size, the
aspect ratio of the voids and
the orientation of the voids in
the material. voids are the main
features here that we're
interested in is pressed metal,
there is no binder. And so then
we can take the statistics of
the morphology. And then we also
that's the structure part. In
the property part, what we do is
we construct these hyper
surfaces for the ignition and
growth rates in in the space
spanned by the shock pressure
and the wide diameter. So we're
doing single void simulations,
we are varying diameters of the
Void varying the shock
pressures, and we collecting
data, and we use the what's
called dynamic Kriging, which is
a kind of GRP approach Gaussian
random process approach to
construct these hyper surfaces.
So, these hyper surfaces tell us
about the mesoscale sensitivity
or the vector that is, you know,
if you if you subject one pore,
to the given pressure, and the
pore is of a certain size, what
is the ignition and growth rate
of hotspots from that one pour.
So somehow, we have to take this
information and convey it to the
macroscale to get the
performance aspect of it. So
this is just a brief picture of
how we populate the parameter
space, which is the pressure and
diameter of the void, we do
numerical simulations here. And
these are adaptively done, where
there's an active learning
process that is in the GRP and
that indicates where we need
more data. So, we then follow
that and do the simulations and
then we have an you know,
measure RMSE of to determine the
convergence of the surrogate in
the hyperscale hypersurface. And
so, then we say okay, now, we
have a hypersurface that we can
use for for our for our
calculations at the macro scale.
Now, so, these are again, based
on the single poll data, we we
do the poor collapse react to
for collapse calculations, we
collect data on the void
collapse in a void area, the
hotspot temperature, the hotspot
area and mass of mass production
of reactive material, that comes
out of one poll. And using that
data, we extract these these
quantities the F dot ignition
and F dot growth, and these are
taken simply from the data and
we calculate the slopes of
these, these this curve which is
the mass fraction reacted, and
from that, from that curve, we
determine the F dot ignition
which is the rate of ignition
due to due to a particular
hotspot. And then we also get
the rate of growth when it
settles down into the growth
phase. So, initially when the
pour pour collapses, you form
this ignition ignites the
material around it and so that's
the ignition phase between one
and two. And then that ignited
hotspot if it survives, if it is
critical, they will grow and
then then we take between when
it's in the steady state growth
phase we take the growth rate.
So that's how we get the F dot
ignition at DOD growth once We
have these dot international
growth, then in order to close
the macro scale simulation, all
we have to do is multiply that F
dot ignition group by the
porosity of the metal. And then
we get what macro scale
requires, which is the lambda
dot ignition and lambda and our
growth. And again, those are
exactly mean exactly the same
things as in Tarvaris ignition
and growth model. So, we kind of
plugged into the ignition growth
modeling framework essentially.
Okay, so, then what we do is
using that information of the
surrogate, we evaluate the
performance and that is done as
follows. So, we do you know, in
a coupon, one dimensional
calculations of shock
propagation of a particular
pressure and pulse width, and
once we propagate the shock to
the homogenized, macroscale
metal, we need this information
of the ladder dot lambda dot
ignition and grow just like in
any ignition and growth model.
And what we do is we get that
from the hypersurfaces. So, for
a particular point, if we know
the pressure there, we can go in
and we know the microstructure
that is the void size and all
that we can go and interrogate
the data from the hypersurfaces.
And then that gives us the heat
release rate in that particular
cell. And so we put that into a
macro scale and we look at, you
know, what happens to the shock.
And if the shock rises to the On
Demand Pressure, then we say
okay, that that's critical,
right. And so that's how we
construct these dreams curve. So
here I'm showing using message
with the method I just
described, which is based on the
surrogate modeling, I'm showing
a comparison between experiment
the black line is the
experiments done at Eglin Air
Force Base for HTML is a
particular microstructure of h2o
mix, which is classified and so
we know you know very well
characterized microstructure and
we use message which is the red
line here to calculate the Jas
curve, that is the sensitivity
curve. And as you can see, you
know, the message does a fairly
good job of of construct of
matching experiment, in terms of
the sensitivity the metro. So
the red line is message, the
pink, the purple line is park
and I will, I will show how that
works in a second. So,
basically, our objective is to
get this E theoretical the
energy, the critical energy for
detonation. And so that's the
data that that best fits this
particular experimental curve.
And our critical energy is very,
very, in good agreement with the
experiment using message. So we
can successfully now telescope,
the microstructure or
information and predict the
sensitivity of, of a metal as a
function of its microstructure.
We have done other other micro
structures as well with success,
Uri, and that that, again, was
provided to us by AFRL. There
are a whole other lots of other
things we've done with the
surrogate based modeling.
They've done inverse modeling,
there is one if you know the, if
you know the criticality can be
determined material properties.
We've done that recently. And
that's worked out in quite
interesting ways. And we're also
doing transfer learning. So if
we know something about h of x,
can we say something about our
dx, and that work is ongoing in
an NSF project on meta learning.
So it's been quite successful,
the message route has been quite
successful. So the second route
of data driven modeling that
we've been pursuing in our Murie
project excuse me, is called
park park stands for physics
aware record and convolution.
This is a paper a couple of two
or three papers that have come
out recently with Steve back
group and this one came out in
science advances this year. And
so I will briefly discuss what
what Park stands for. So Park is
part of a larger effort that is
part of a package that we are
working on called matter IQ,
which is an AI based toolkit for
materials by design. So, Park
fits into that as as the DD
model. And its work jointly Of
course with Steve and Fung and
and we are just to give you a
very broad idea of what meta IQ
is all about. So in meta IQ,
which is again for metals but
design what we are trying to do
is we are We have different
components to the package. The
first one is a synthetic
synthetic microstructure
generator. Because we don't have
a large number of
microstructural samples, we want
to take in archetypal samples
that maybe you have one image
for, but then generate an
ensemble of samples, so we can
do statistical modeling of it.
And then we can actually do DNS
simulations on that ensemble. So
that's the synthetic
microstructure part. Then we
have machine learning models for
various purposes. And I'll
highlight some of them in the
following segment. And then we
have actor critic design
optimizers. So we can optimize
micro structures based on their
performance characteristics. And
then we connect everything,
because we have Fortran modules
for for the solvers. There's
legacy modules. And then we have
all the Python and pytorch, we
have wrappers that connect all
of these into an actual design
tool. So so that's the framework
in which Parque fits as the DD
platform. So in so the matter IQ
DD platform is, in terms of the
structure, it's a deep learning
based approach for generating
and experimenting with synthetic
micro structures. So we can
change micro structures in
various ways to conduct these
experiments, and I'll describe
how that works. And then we do
simulations and the simulations
then feed into a deep learning
based approach to predict meso
scale dynamics, and then that
then feeds into the macro scale
performance evaluation. So this
loop is basically closed by
Park. So let me talk a little
bit about the structure part and
how DD works into the structure
part. Here we can synthesize
micro structures using CNNs. And
this work has been published in
a couple of papers last the last
few years, starting from 2020.
So basically, we use Gann
approach for synthesizing micro
structures. If you're very
broadly, Gann is an adversarial
contest between watt generator
network and a discriminator
network where the generator
tries to deceive the
discriminator by generating sub
samples of microstructures in
the discriminator, then being
the discriminator you know,
attempts to push the generator
closer and closer to the target
image by by minimizing an error
between the two between the
candidate microstructure and the
target microstructure. And
eventually, you know, through
this process, they converge to a
particular hopefully to the
target microstructure or
facsimiles near off. So that's
the that's the strategy and it's
in the paper by Shannon at all
in 2020. And basically, the what
we have shown in that paper is
that we can take one snapshot of
an energetic material
microstructure and generate many
many similar microstructure with
similar characteristics. So,
then we can do numerical
experiments on them. So, these
are some ground truth samples of
micro structures that we
obtained from from AFRL. The
middle row is a transfer
learning based approach and
results from that and lower row
is the Gann final Gann approach
that we settled on. As you can
see the Gann approach gives nice
clean microstructures the
transfer learning approach can
have some local glitches these
are close ups of parts of this
micro structure, and we found
the gap gap and actually
produces nice crisp micro
structures that emulate the real
microstructure. And we also done
in that paper, we show
quantitative comparisons of
various statistics of these
microstructures showing that the
black line here is ground truth
and these are probability
densities of the Void size,
aspect ratio and orientation of
the voids. And we show that you
know our again approach produces
real microstructures with
quantitative similarity as well.
So you know, we're capturing the
the characteristics of real
microstructure and this can also
be extended to three dimensions
the The paper also addresses 3d
micro structures or in this
particular case of sandstone,
where you can take the ground
truth sandstone, microstructure
and synthesize it and generate
ensembles of synthesized micro
structures. And these are
showing 2d slices of these
microstructures and quantitative
comparisons, they're very dense,
I won't go into it, but you can
look at various metrics of the
quantitative characteristics of
the real microstructure and
synthesize and we show that you
know, the synthesized micro
structures capture the
characteristics of the, of the
real microstructures Remapping.
So, that's, that's the structure
generation part now, what this
allows us to do in a materials
by design standpoint is that we
can manipulate the
microstructure. So, once we have
the baseline microstructure that
that emulates the real
microstructure, then we can can
turn knobs literally in in the
generator, basically we are
modulating the latent variables
and by modulating the latent
variables, we can change the
structure of the metal. So, for
example, just to show one one
instance by performing a
particular operation here we go
from this initial small
microstructure, small grain size
microstructure and we can
manipulate the my the latent
variables to go towards larger
finally, to a larger
microstructure. And we can do
this in for various other things
as well for example, here we can
control the orientation of the
of the crystals or the voids. In
fact, we have shown that
depending on the void
orientation, the sensitivity of
the material can change
massively wider oriented along
the shock propagation direction
tend to be more sensitive than
voids that are oriented normal
to the prop propagation. So, we
can actually investigate the
effects of the orientation of
voids and so on and so, we can
now kind of manipulate the
microstructures virtually to to
get different void void
orientations, we can also look
at mixtures of sizes by
modulating the latent variables,
the uniformity when you if we
mark toggle the latent variables
in a certain way we get bimodal
mixtures and so on and so forth.
So, we can now control the
microstructures virtually and
these are done you know these
are a picture of the latent
variable weights here and by
different weights of the of the
latent variables, we can we get
different crystal sizes void
sizes and so, this allows for
flexibility in making different
micro structures, we can also
paint micro structures using
this approach, which is to say
that we can spatially vary the
microstructure. So, this is
microstructure was generated
with small grains on one end and
large grains on the other end.
So, we can do that we can also
paint micro structural
regions. So, here we have taken
the Hawkeye which is the
University of Iowa symbol. And
we've gotten permission to do
that from our, from our
university, which is very
important. And what we show here
is that we want to put large
crystals in this yellow region
and small crystals in the black
region. So, we imprinted
imprinted that haka image in on
to this microstructure if you
can see here, these are the
large crystals, and then the
surroundings a small crystals,
and we actually 3d printed this,
we have a depth score grant with
the collaborator, Professor
Shawn song. And he he does
pressure jet printing. And so
this is sugar crystals, of
course, being university that's
we can only handle sugar. And
so, you know, here you can see
that, you know, there's a, the
Hawkeyes, larger crystals are
printed over here. And these are
all small crystals. And zooming
into the this region here you
can see the large crystals of
the Hawkeye symbol. So so we can
actually transmit our micro
structures to somebody who does
3d printing and actually do
that. And then of course,
finally, we will use these micro
structures, the synthetic ones,
and look at the response shock
response a bit in simulation. So
this is for large, small
crystals, and it's for large
crystals. And you can see the
growth rate of hotspots is very
different in the two of them. So
that's that's the facility now
we're also doing other things.
Irene Fung, who's actually at
Livermore for the summer, I
think is working on manipulating
micro structures to explore
design in the following way that
she's actually she can actually
modulate damage on the
microstructure. So she's coming
up with a deep learning approach
so that we can take a input
microstructure. And we can
actually remove all the damage
from in there and then re damage
it in a controlled way. So that
we can insert as as much damage
as we want, because we want to
study the effect of, of damaged
micro structures on the
sensitivity. So that's the idea
over there. Okay, so, in fact, I
will actually, in the interest
of time skip through earnings
work, because they want to get
to part I think I'm, I'm
actually mean. So how much time
do I have?
Maybe five to 10 minutes. Okay.
Let's say 10 minutes.
Okay, I'm gonna take 10 Because
I, okay, so in part, we're
basically what part does is that
it? It learns from the DNS
stimulations, and then it can
actually do predictions once
it's learned from it. So you
know, we are asking questions
like can can we train an AI
model to assimilate the physics
of energy localization, can an
AI model serve as a surrogate
for DNS calculations, and can AI
models provide physical insight
so we don't want it to be a
black box, we want
interpretability. So we want to
get information out of out of
park. And as I said, Park fits
into this, this overall
framework where as a data driven
modeling entity, so we this is
the DDS DD model that we're
using in the larger metros
design optimization and
discovery framework of matter
IQ. Park basically, the idea
behind Park is that we are going
to formulate the shock and use
hotspot evolution as a dynamical
system. That is we pick this
variable x from the physics of
the problem. And in our
particular case, we pick x to be
a function basically consists of
a vector of the temperature of
the hotspots, the pressure in
the in the domain and the
microstructure, because the
microstructure evolves. So it
goes from becoming from voids to
wide collapse, and then
eventually to become hotspots.
So we want to track the
evolution of all three things,
the temperature, the pressure,
and the microstructure. And so
we train the model to learn
those three aspects, the
evolution of those three aspects
from numerical simulations. And
that's the idea behind Park. So
basically, Park is assimilates
knowledge of how that evolution
of this field X takes place.
And, and we formulate it as a
recurrent recurrent neural
network where we have
differentiator in integrator
networks, and these
differentiator and integrated
networks, assimilate the
derivatives of the variable x,
and then they perform the
integration. And the time, the
time evolution is, is a
simulated within Park to
eventually predict what happens
at the end when the hotspots
finally grow and merge in the
metro. So just to show an
example of a park calculation,
so this, the top row is DNS for
this microstructure. This is the
park prediction for that
microstructure after training.
So so you can see that sorry. So
Park does a good job of
predicting what happens hotspot,
the location of the hotspot, the
frequency of the hotspots, and
so on. And the advantage is
that, while the DNS would take
days on HPC Park would be would
just be, you know, really quick
prediction. So it predicts the
time evolution of hotspots. And
it also predicts the pressure.
As you can see, the pressure is
not as well predicted as the
temperature because the pressure
has smaller gradients than the
temperature the temperature is
much sharper, but it does a
fairly decent job of predicting
the pressure evolution as well.
So this x which is an avoid
collapse, evolution of
microstructure evolution, so
this is in a park exercised on
many, many different micro
structures. The left side ground
truth and the rights are
predicted it's I know it's very
difficult to see this, but
basically the overall messages
in a park predictions are in
good agreement. And this is a
quantitative comparison. So for
various microstructures we've
worked Park and we've done DNS
and the confidence intervals
here are the microstructure
variability due to
microstructure variability. So
this is the hotspot temperature
versus time. The Hotspot area
versus time as you can see park
in the mean and also in terms of
the distribution. Park produces
good hotspot area evolution over
time, in good agreement with the
ground truth, the rate of change
of area of the hotspot versus
time is also in good agreement
with the, with the ground truth.
So we get the hotspot dynamics.
Right. Now we've used this part
model to do the multiscale full
multi scale. So basically that
came out in a paper in cap
actually just just just
recently, ever we can take a
macro scale image sample, we can
do the statistical analysis of
it, we do DNS simulations
between Park and then Park
predicts the the hotspot growth
rate and so on. And we feed that
to the macroscale simulation and
predict SDT and the criticality
on going up. And this is the Jas
envelope of our predicted by
message. So message sorry, park
park is the purple one messages
the red one. So the two
approaches somewhat in the in
the low pressure range. As you
can see, there's more
sensitivity, and they straddle
the experimental data, while in
the high pressure range, they do
a very good agreement with each
other. And also with experiment.
So this is, this is a
demonstration that we now can
put all of the pieces together
in a multiscale framework. Now
the question is, of course, did
we learn physics? Or is it just
pictures? And so can it tell us
something in order to
investigate this, we tested Park
in many, many ways. First, we
tested this to a, an off the
shelf physics naive models for
for learning. And we showed that
park does a better job or you
know, in fact, some of the
physics naive off the shelf
codes that we tried this on, you
know, did not match with the,
with the ground truth, but we
are able to match closely with
the ground truth. The second
thing we tested was looking at
time evolution beyond training,
that is we trained part for a
certain time, and then we let
part go. And then we do the DNS
for those longer times and see
if it captures the evolution
correctly. Beyond the training
time averages and extrapolation
and park does that successfully.
Then, we also looked at outlier
micro structures, we had trained
park on a certain set of micro
structures, and then we picked
microstructures parts of the
microstructured that were quite
quite different from what we are
trained Park on and we looked at
whether it can actually predict
the you know the behavior of
those sensitivity of those. For
example, very, very large
crystal like that, we do a DNS.
And then we also look at Park
and as with the park and predict
where the hotspots are. We also
tested Park to unseen loading
conditions that is we trained
park on a certain set of
pressures and we looked at other
pressures. And there as well
Park captures the physics and
gives us the hotspot correct
hotspot growth rates. So, aside
from this, we also asked the
question can park tell us some
information about the physics?
So in order to do this, we asked
a question. From our simulation,
we noted that only a small
subset of voids generate
hotspots. And why is that what
is particularly interesting
about those critical voids, and
can we get information about
this. So we used the saliency
map which is a derivative of the
temperature array with respect
to the microstructure. And we
have these two fields, the
temperature field and the
microstructure appeal. So we can
then establish this the
sensitivity matrix. And that is
what I'm calling the saliency
map field. And so if we
threshold the saliency map
field, we find that there are
the saliency map tells us which
voids went critical and formed
hotspots. And so we can
superimpose this on the
microstructure. And we can
examine these voids that caused
the hotspots, as you can see the
the vast majority of voids
failed to produce hotspots. So
then we're asking what is
special about these critical
hotspots, and we zoom in there,
and we try to correlate that the
morphology information with the
sensitivity information. And
what we find is, you know, by
doing this analysis is the
following. And it's actually,
you know, we, it matches with,
with the physics that we had
earlier learned in various other
works, which is that this is the
this the critical voice and this
is the non critical voice. And
as you can see, the critical
voice don't look terribly
different from the non critical
voice. You know, but there are
subtle differences and there's
subtle differences are as
follows. So, if you look at the
average voice diameter of
critical voids, they tend to be
smaller than the average
diameter of the non critical
points. If you look at the
aspect ratio of the critical
voice versus non critical voice
as they elongate Ignis, they're
not terribly different, but if
you look at the orientation, it
has a very strong effect. So,
critical voids are nearly
horizontal with respect to the
immediate horizontal with
respect to the shop direction,
whereas the non critical words
are oriented much more in
parallel to the sharp direction.
So that orientation has a
significant impact on
sensitivity.
Okay, so
I think I can summarize this
now. So, basically park can
predict Well, the response can
be B, we used about 35 DNS
simulation, so, the data is not
terribly large, and part manages
to gather information from that.
And we showed that part does
produce physically meaningful
and physically insightful
results that we can interrogate.
And so, I think there are
further developments of park
that I will not go into right
now, we are working on improving
accuracy for week hotspots. And,
and, and other other accuracy
issues and robustness issues.
But so let me summarize, finish
by putting this slide on meta
IQ. So, basically, we now have
the ability to manipulate
structures, we can do
simulations that feed into data
driven models, and we can
predict the macroscale phenomena
of sensitivity in a multiscale
setting.
So, I'll finish there.
Thank you. Thank you so much for
the wonderful talk today. Let's
have a q&a session. I don't see
any question in chat room. So,
if you anyone has questions,
please unmute yourself and ask
on a knowledge, base your hands
or unmute yourself and just
speak either way.
Anyone? Larry, yeah. Yeah.
I was wondering, had you looked
at applying your technique to
samples of varying initial
density where you might have
porous materials versus very
dense materials?
Yes, Larry, thanks for the
question I we did two
microstructures you know, we
don't have access to too many
samples, we did an AR 10
microstructure and and a plus
five microstructure both press H
MX. And our predictions of
sensitivity were were in accord
with experiments on those two
micro structures both done at
AFRL Eglin we are actually
working on a third now we are
doing PB X's and we are working
on a third microstructure as
well which is very different
from those two micro structures.
So the porosity is much lower.
So, we are doing that right now.
Very, very impressive work.
Thank you very much.
Thank you Laurie. Just to add
clarification to the old hen had
a 7% porosity and the class five
had a 14 14% porosity. So quite
different microstructure
Okay. Thank you. Thank you.
Okay, we have a another question
in chapter one. And by Cooper,
he asked, did you look at the
difference in the surface area
for the critical versus non
critical voice
therapists area No,
so, this, so, we looked at
diameter aspect ratio right. So,
aspect ratio is not terribly
sensitive to the aspect ratio,
it is sensitive to the diameter.
So, this surface area does
matter. And in fact, this is you
know, common common knowledge
and surface parasitic surface
area does matter. So, smaller
voids tend to be more sensitive
than the larger voids for a
given aspect ratio. So, that's,
you know, that sort of or
finding a specific surface there
for a given porosity then that
means that there will be a
larger surface area specific
surface area with smaller
points. So, that's specific
surface area is important.
And it's consistent with both
Park findings as well as message
findings.
Thank you. You have a curve,
you know the results of the
massive results of the curve
from the park. One is under
estimating the other one is over
estimate Adding in physics point
of view or application point of
view fits fits is more valuable
is under estimating is better or
overestimating is better in
criticality as
well, I think we're having
needed would be better best, I
guess, but I know, I sort of
have an in. So let me actually
Oh, yes. You were mentioning
this one, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Previous one. Yeah,
that one? Yeah. This one? Yeah.
For some reason, oh, hang on one
second. Okay. Yeah. So this,
this region is the most
difficult part. So you know,
this one is actually fairly
straightforward to predict,
which, you know, is, it's
heartening that we can do that,
but but I would, I would rather
have good predictions over here.
The problem over here is in we
working on this is that over
here, it's not truly
hydrodynamic the void collapse
here. So this there is a, there
is also physics missing, I think
at this in this area of the
plot. Because as you approach
about five GPA, and so on, you
can get effects of shear bands
and other strength related
aspects of the material. And
those are not terribly well
modeled currently in our work.
And we are trying to remedy that
by by using better physical
models for this to represent the
strength. And we made some
progress on that. So that's
ongoing work. But I think so I
would, in answering your
question young so I don't know
if this is particularly issue
with the more the DD models
themselves? Or is it actually a
misrepresentation of the physics
there? Until we fix the physics
I would not know what to say
about those two things.
You know, okay. Yeah.
Looks like if you average those
two, then you'd be in good
shape. Today, this
is kayo. I've got a couple of
questions. In regards to park I
didn't see a void void
interaction term or a is some
kind of provision for void void
interaction, what role do you
believe that plays in what
determines a critical defect
morphology, size
orientation, whatever. The point
in my in my estimation, the void
void interaction part is
inherent clean learned by Park.
Whereas in the message model, we
have to have another surrogate
model, which we have, and we
have to insert it into message
which we have done in order to
get these curves. So, in
message, we have to make an
effort to include worldwide
interaction because it relies on
single word calculations.
Whereas because pork relies on a
full DNS, and the full DNS
already has the worldwide
interactions in it, I think pork
actually takes that into
account. Now, having said that,
we've done recent work that
shows that for white small void
sizes, by which I mean about a
one micron diameter void sizes
via interactions may not be a
terribly strong effect. For
larger void diameters, we find
worldwide interactions are very
strong effect. So I think in
this instance, because the void
sizes in class five center
around about point five micron I
don't know if the void size
interactions will play a major
role in in this in the
discrepancies that exist in the
predicted predictions for this
particular case. But I think
Park actually should take into
account wide wide interactions.
Yeah, of course, you have the
ignition and ignition
criticality, and then the growth
and you know, there there are
opportunities in both phases to
take place. But, yeah, I mean, I
think that the Yeah, it seems
like some kind of provision for
part going forward that
considers the possibility but
clearly having first you know,
as a first order the the void
itself is probably one of the I
guess, like you're saying the
most one One of the most
important things, yes, in
regards to the low pressure
regime that you're pointing to?
Do you believe that there are
fundamental mechanism changes?
It seems like you're implying
that by saying over a certain
pressure regime, it's
hydrodynamic, you know, under
that could be more of a viscous
and other kinds of interactions
that perhaps we don't normally
encounter, whether it be surface
physics or other kinds of modes
or what have you. Right. Have
any thoughts about that
specifically, mechanism changes?
Yes, yes,
I certainly do, actually. So if
you look at, you know, where,
where we are about five GPA,
five GPA, is about the, about
the pressure at which we find
that most, the voids are sort of
borderline, they're about
they're not collapsing in full
hydrodynamic mode. And if we do
the calculations of that, in
fact, with the Johnson cook
model, the independent model and
so on, to that you guys actually
have published on we find that,
you know, there are, there are
shear bands, and there is a
significant change of mode of
collapse of the Void from,
whereas for high pressures, it's
hydrodynamic, you know, in the
jetting mode, for the lower
pressures, it tend to be more of
a closure mode. In fact, as he
goes lower pressures, it closes
the sideways pinching mode,
rather than a jet mode. And in
sharp, the shear bands play a
very large role. So I think
there is there is definitely
some kind of mechanism
transition, because below we
know about, you know, five GPA
or so you really don't get
criticality. So, you know, the
wide may collapse, but it
collapses so weakly, that you
don't get criticality. So there
is there is something here
happening both in terms of,
well, first of all, in terms of
the mode of collapse, and the
strength of the material, kind
of playing a role. But secondly,
also, I think this, this region
is much more sensitive to the MS
chemical kinetics models, and
we've done quite a bit of
examination of that, which can,
you know, this curve that I'm
showing even for message can
move all the way out here with a
lawyer, you know, with a chemist
in one chemistry bottle reaction
chemistry model, and all the way
to the other side with another
chemistry model. And we found
that, in fact, doing an inverse
analysis that the best fit to
the experimental data from the
chemistry models comes from, you
know, the Henson, one equation,
global kinetics model. So, that
also plays a role clearly that
the chemical kinetics because it
temperatures here, due to avoid
collapse, and lower pressures
tend to be borderline. So if you
if you it's very, so the
reaction kinetics model is very
sensitive in that region in
predicting the criticality. So
there's a lot going on in that
region that really needs a lot
of looking into, and that's
actually the interesting region
for us. Because, you know,
that's the threshold. And if we
can predict that correctly, then
you know, that that's not a
terribly great model. So, so
this variation here is of
concern, but I would, I would
first try to get the physics
right before trying to, you
know, figure out which DD model
is better, in that sense. So,
there's a lot going on there too
much work to be done in that
region.
Thank you, Dave. And Greg, great
talk. Thanks, Gail. Any other
questions from audience?
Well, I'm, I have a rather a
comments than questions about
the naming, physics aware you
know, there are a lot of active
research going on in physics
simulation and and also, you
know, the machine learning side.
One example is a physics
informed neural network. And
another one is more traditional
way of bringing the physics into
the data model is using the
projection base for this to
reduce certain model. It's clear
that why they are calling their
data to do method is physics
aware physics informed because
they actually using underlying
governing equations to build a
data driven model, but but your
park model I don't see that. And
I do, I do see that data is
generated from DNS model, which
is, you know, solving the
physics governing equations. But
in theory, Data driven it's the
physics model is not directly
integrated into the into the
model. So, yeah there is a
something debatable here whether
you can call it physics aware, I
know that you have shown that
you know generalizability at the
end, you know, your park model
actually predicted some physical
characteristics right some some
ratio the rate, but still I
don't see where the physics is
incorporated in the process of
building the motor
itself. So, you
So, yes, so, this has come up
quite frequently, especially
with the pin the pin framework
and so on. So, clearly in pin
there are you know, there are in
particular the divergence free
velocity constraint is built
into the network, right.
Not not only that actual
governing equations, they are
operating
not absolutely, so, in some
sense, we are much more or
somewhere we are in between that
or that philosophy of of making
the network emulate the full
governing equations, and the
reduced order modeling, in the
sense that we are trying to
learn because it is intended to
be a bridge between the mezzo
and macro scale simulations, we
are abstracting from the measure
scale, what is physically
relevant to the macro scale, in
our particular case, what is
physically relevant is the
temperature field, the pressure
field and the microstructural
evolution.
You know, the system of
equations we
are solving is very, very large,
it is a reactive, fully
compressible system with
interfaces in full interfacial
dynamics. You know, we we don't
want to be in the situation
where we impose upon the
network, the need to solve that
entire system of equations where
that's not the idea here, the
idea is to use some of our
expert intuition in picking the
physics that needs to be learned
by the network. And we coupled
those three elements, the
temperature, the pressure, and
the microstructure within the
vector x. And so we are trying
to look at the coupling of the
physics between the shock and
the hotspot and the void. And in
that sense, we are keying in
what is required in terms of
physical ingredients into the
network. And we are making it
actually emulate the the
evolution of the process through
the differential equations.
So, you know,
if we don't do that, we don't
get the results for the hotspot
evolution that as I've shown, we
don't get the correct results.
So and then, you know, the other
tests, I showed that we are
actually capturing physics, and
we are making, you know,
extracting insights that are
physically meaningful, and match
with expert knowledge. I think
in those senses, you know, what
we have is a physically aware
system. You know, it's not it's
not physical physics is not the
same as the physics inform
neural networks. It's not the
philosophy, the philosophy, it's
not a reduced order model. It's,
it's using physics and physical
knowledge and integrating that
into a neural network that
produces for us what we need,
which is taking the information
from the meso scale and
transmitting it to the macro
scale. So that's, that's my,
that's my overall kind of
outlook on what we are trying to
do.
Okay, okay.
Is it Is there any other
questions?
Well, I mean, we actually pass
the 10 minutes
to sorry,
no, no, no, no, sorry. It means,
you know, we are very interested
in your work. So I think it's a
good time to wrap up. Well,
let's thank our speaker today
for the wonderful talk and
wonderful q&a sessions. A lot of
applause, here. And yeah, let's,
let's wrap up here. Thank you,
everyone. And if you do have a
question, please email who they
directly I'm sure Woody is going
to answer your questions
recently. Well, and then yeah,
and then, you know, of course
the future collaborations
between Lawrence Livermore and
and your group and I think it's
it's already going on so let's
continue to do so. Thank you
they were the ones that
thank you guys bye